I really wanted you to remember my name
so I brought this and I hope that it
helps remember who I am I will remember
and I feel so bad about that do you
[Music]
do you know how many women you kissed on
night one
don't worry because I counted
[Music]
I counted seven
foreign
[Music]
you know there's no shame in the game
all right I get it I get it did you go
in thinking that you would be kissing a
bunch of women or just you just followed
your heart and those lips
hold the heart and the lips no
um for night one I I made sure to not
like have you know for myself like any
rules or any like specific way to do
this like I didn't look to any anyone
else to try to navigate the right way I
just went in fully experiencing it and
like feeling and meeting all the women I
could like that was my first priority
though was just meeting as many women as
possible now the the kissing you know
the heart wants what the heart wants and
if the connection's there absolutely I
love that you wasted no time I mean even
at the limo entrance with Bailey like
you just went for it gotta do what you
gotta do
I'm so sorry
what how does this happen
it's just like shocking I don't ever
think was gonna be like this we also do
see you crying in that super tease so do
you think you did more kissing or crying
this season pretty close to both I don't
know um I mean the whole thing it's
it's unlike anything you can ever
imagine and you are you know put in
really tough situations you know there's
little to no sleep at all for the entire
time a lot of champagne a lot of
champagne a lot of hangovers but also a
lot of
you know like risking it all like I'm
just like you know I know what I want
and like I'm
looking for that so much and feelings
are at stake and you know the women are
doing the same and you're just laying
your heart out on the line well yeah you
have to commit to the process right and
that means being vulnerable right yeah
it's painful at times for sure and you
know it's so painful not to kiss all
these women too you know you just that's
what you signed up for it's what you got
to do so tough career will you accept
this Rose
yeah thank you thank you
there were a few women that stood out to
me in that first episode but I'm curious
about like what stands out to you about
them when I say their name now so Greer
who got your first impressionable yeah
so with Greer
um that was awesome because you know
with such a chaotic night that's just
going a million miles an hour she was
able to make it seem really calm and
like kind of take me out of the the wild
or the weirdness so when I gave her that
first impression Rose I was like you
know what like that moment when I was
talking to her it just felt like I
wasn't at night one of the Mansion of
the bachelor like it just felt different
you know what's it out to you about
Katie you guys had a great conversation
she was one of the seven women you kiss
and you both are from Austin yeah that's
I mean crazy it's like I was you know
living in Austin she's living in Austin
and how did we not meet before this so I
don't know it's pretty surreal to to
have her there and very sweet and it was
a great conversation it looked like it
clicked for you there that was yeah
definitely very early you know my heart
wasn't feeling it yeah I never want to
force that and I don't want to put you
through something that's not real
because I know what it feels like to be
went on and I don't want that for you
I'm sorry I just I I don't don't see a
future with us now what about Madison
who you actually sent home before the
rose ceremony
yeah yeah so you know with that
um you know I wish her nothing but the
best but but basically with that it's
you can't force anything and that's kind
of how I approach that like I preach
honesty from the very beginning and if
you ever have to force it especially
in this experience when when time is so
limited you know I don't want to waste
her time sure and I don't want to waste
anyone else's time and um you know I
just felt that that was the right thing
to do and did you feel like I don't know
was it easier to let her down because
you had that private moment one-on-one
versus maybe you know not giving her a
rose at the ceremony or was it harder oh
it was difficult for sure I mean no one
like wants to have that conversation you
know I didn't want to but I think it was
necessary because like she deserved to
have that conversation okay Anastasia
are you here for me yes I don't know if
I believe Anastasia in the super teas we
hear you say you don't know if you
believe her what causes you to say that
um
that's a great question you're gonna
have to tune in and see but it's a
little juicy yeah okay yeah that's some
that's uh some of those emotions that
you're talking about huh those come into
play well it's a little bit of uh fears
coming to light okay that's all I'll say
yeah perfect all right Jess the girls
call her manipulative in the clip I'm
upset that I haven't gotten a 101. I
don't trust Jazz she's manipulative why
is that do you know you know I don't
fully know you don't I don't okay so is
that something you're saving for
tell-all I think so you have some
questions yourselves right I do you have
a notepad are you writing them down I'm
a little surprised are we taking notes
as you start watching this season my
little sharks okay
this is my worst fear falling in love
with two people it's terrifying all
right now looking ahead to the rest of
the season we'll do a little speed rap
you said your worst fear has fallen in
love with two people does this come true
find out you said all you wanted from
these women was for them to be open and
honest with you about their feelings did
anyone not meet that expectation
throughout this journey
I mean without spooling too much 30
women's a lot of women and there are
different motives I'll just say that
okay uh you know Jesse told us this is
maybe the most romantic and emotional
season of The Bachelor even said it kind
of gave him the throwback Vibes of
earlier Seasons because there's less
drama and more romance do you agree with
that
in a sense yes but I actually a little
bit disagree with him I think from like
the past year or so uh Bachelor
Bachelorette has been very You Know
Drama focused and it's been like a
little
like
in excess of just like okay this is a
little crazy like the shrimp stuff and
all this there's definite there's
definite drama to where it's like like
there's
like I call it like real life drama so
it's stuff that's not like thrown in
there or unnecessary it's like real like
emotions real situations where people
have issues and they're confronted and
so it's not as crazy as it may seem as
like fighting over shrimp but it's still
like people can relate to it emotion and
poison me so I'll see there's maybe like
honestly like 15 shrimp in there
are you engaged
I'm trying to repeat the question are
you engaged let me see your hand you're
it's in his pocket so cleverly huh are
you happy
I'll tell you this I'm very happy and I
did find love but to see what that looks
like you're gonna have to tune it you
know that's that's what I gotta say
[Music]